writers intrinsically are always seeking
you know even as i speak
the right word to use
why screenwriting that's a great
question to start with uh i
i think it's just basically
um two things and
one is um
when
when i was young
the thing that
came
before i wanted to tell stories which i
think is very integral to
to wanting to
write screenplays
er is a
is a love for movies and a love for
cinema and so
i think i just became like a movie
addict first
um
without any sort of concern
whatsoever for
the idea of writing a screenplay
um just just kind of
getting a rush from
from movies and watching movies and
talking about movies and
and
wanting to introduce my
my friends to movies so
for me i think that was the
the the first
the the amuse boosh
on the palette before i launched into
and to storytelling um storytelling was
something else
um storytelling was
the
the idea that there was a
message that i want to convey
um a statement that i wanted to say and
usually like and and that didn't really
sort of progress until i for me um i was
in my early 20s
and i
i had these ideas and i would see these
these great films from from people
that were expressing um at the time for
me
um
these kind of subjects that dealt with
things that that hit me
in the heart in in um
at my core
um for who i was a young adult as a
young black male adult
and um
um one example of course would be um
well two examples would be john
singleton and spike lee
um
and um
and i and i thought hey you know i
want to tell stories that have like
messages that are akin to that that have
that kind of
you know that that that relate to you
know to to to people like me
so um that was the impetus
and
then i went on a journey of trying to
discover how to do that um
and
[Music]
and that
um that entailed um
um mining what i love about um the
written word
um
and um
and and
and and and that also
involves
you know
a love of literature
um
a
love of storytelling of all types
i think that
that screenplays are usually just
elaborate short stories
um just
unspooled
and in in a in a slow fashion
um across 12 beats which would make it
3x
but
but yeah i i hope that wasn't too long
no it was perfect you said something
about uh mining the written word that's
interesting
yeah
well
it it what i mean by that is
is that um
when it comes to
writing screenplays specifically um
you're telling us
a story in pictures
and to tell a story in pictures you have
to
use these um
these um blunt
little tools that are called words
um and you have to find um new and
different ways to
use those words juxtapose those words
abuse those words even
um
to
make a picture out of a scene
uh
if you if you have a scene in which
there isn't any sort of banter if there
you don't have two characters
exchanging dialogue
you have to
create
what amounts to an interpretation
or a blueprint
that um that the director is going to
work from
and the and
and on all the other attendant people
involved
so
that is mining the written word you you
have to find the right words to do so
you know so i mean
so even as i speak right now you'll find
this is this affects
i think the dna
of
of writers and screenwriters
because
um i think writers intrinsically are
always seeking
you know even as i speak
the right word to use
because when it comes to to writing
you're sitting there
you're being still
you're being patient
if you are if you were
born sometime before um 1980 you were in
front of a blank page
if you if you were born somewhere after
you know you were you're in um you're in
front of um
a blank screen and you're waiting
you're waiting to get
just the right word to string next to
another word
to
get right
to be a correct
approximation
of
what you want
the
the the director or producer
or even the reader to take away
from the experience of that scene
how long have you been doing this
i've been i've been writing scripts
in
you know
a scattered fashion for
um
i'll be told um like about like 23 years
and
yeah that's long and short
23 years and so
was there a point when you almost walked
away from screenwriting absolutely
or should i ask which time or what what
happened absolutely like like um
i'd say a few times um
early in the game
um especially when it seemed really hard
but the thing that kept bringing me back
was
was pretty easy is it wouldn't let me go
you know i
i think
that's a complex thing to answer because
i think if
you intrinsically
um feel
you know called to write um you know
people say that and it sounds really
pretentious it's like
it's like you were called to be a part
of the monastery like you're a jesuit
somewhere and since this is not i i know
it sounds pretentious but
it it does actually exist in
and if you um if you survey a number of
writers they will they will sometimes
use that phrase
because they
they find that they can't
they can't pull themselves or wrestle
wrestle themselves away from the
computer
that they have to come back and they
have to work at something because it's
nagging at them and it won't
it won't stop nagging at them until
until it's finished
and so for me it was like that and it
only was it was only
when after a period of time in which
it started to become a little facile it
started to become a little easy that i
you know i was like okay well i'm
i'm just going to keep going
you know
so um
there are other things too um
there's uh there's little lessons that
you learn along the way
um there is there's examples um from
from other writers that you pick up that
um give you um
a really um strong um skill set to um
to to use and to borrow from
um that
make it
real real simple in my mind um
you know i can i can expound on that for
like like
oh maybe two hours
and that i'm actually not kidding so
if we wanted to get into that but but
yeah there's stuff like that
so you found it got easier for you
and you were okay with the fact that
there was something
sort of pulling you to do this that it
was it was it almost felt like it was
beyond your control
yeah um absolutely um
it's
yeah that's basically what it is um
if if i wanted to
um
to get a little bit more flowery about
it you know you know some people you
know
some people believe in a higher power
some people believe in a muse
you know so um
i think that um
with writing you know there's always
something that um
that is pulling you
towards writing it
and the story
and what kind of stories were you pulled
toward i mean you said there were
certain
filmmakers john singleton spike lee that
you wanted to emulate that you wanted to
make movies similar to theirs yeah yeah
in the beginning um
in the beginning i was very um
interested in writing stories
um that
were
were kind of um
carbon copies
of
of the kind of stories that they were
telling
uh that that soon started to evolve um i
started becoming interested in telling a
little bit more
um
action-oriented
uh
almost um elongated well not really
elongated but like a sort of cinematic
comic book
um-esque type stories because i love
comic books and i grew up on comic books
and
and that started to become incorporated
into the kind of
um
writing i was doing
and all the while um as i was developing
my craft i was you know as usual i'm
seeing more movies more kinds of movies
different kinds of movies
i'm a big proponent of
of writing styles that aren't
exclusive to what happens in hollywood
or in america
um i think that what happens in europe
and and britain i think the hong kong um
filmmakers and writers are
excellent
um
i think
you know for example of course you know
john woo wong car y
um the european filmmakers uh michael
hanukkah uh christophe kozlowski
um mike lee
uh
these are all um
they all provide a different
um
a different set of tools that you can
also bring and use and so along the way
i found myself almost kind of coming
full circle back to
what i wanted to tell in the first place
or the kind of stories i wanted to tell
in the first place but with a more
assured voice with my voice
as opposed to being
more of a
carbon copy or
a copy
michael clayton
um interesting love that movie um
why i love that movie
is a couple reasons
i think
that
that one of the finest
filmmakers and writers
and the business is tony gilroy
um
his work is indelible um the
his screenplays
are extraordinary
um if you want to talk about
terse um terse action
suspense
drama
um and and and
and any kind of suspense that feels
rooted in reality as opposed to being
too cartoonish um that is um tony gilroy
and um if you know for anyone who
doesn't you know know his um
his um
attach his name to to his phones we're
talking um the devil's advocate he wrote
he wrote the the the the first three
born movies
um and of course um the the the gorgeous
um and um and beautiful film uh michael
clayton um which is basically
about a character um
about a man who is um
as i was saying a little earlier is um
he's stuck in a sort of nomads land
um because he has um
he has this
this he's burdened by by being able to
do certain things that don't
do that that render him anti-social
um in the world
um yet he's still a very um useful
figure he he's a commodity
and um
he's uh he's he's a commodity that um is
to the detriment of his um
of his own um his own well-being in in
many ways
so um
[Music]
love that film um
what's really great about that film
though
is
what it does and what what it blends is
that
it
it takes all the excitement
that you get all the boys stuff that you
like
you know if you're a boy
um
with um with um
you know um
bad guys and and and and and good guys
and and and good triumphing over evil
and
and all and and the gray areas that
exist in between
and it marries it with um
with
with drama that is really really um
i think socially
um relevant and gives a message and
harkens back to
a lot of those
70s films and those are the films i grew
up on and were the were the films that i
became a fan of
um when i was a kid
those were films like sydney lumet's
films
like
dog day afternoon or
or serpico or
you know um
any any really any of those network
network
phenomenal film but yeah
right and and where you were talking
about
the gray area in between and and
sometimes where the gangster in the film
is not actually the worst character in
the end we find out that it was the the
one that had the appearance of
sort of the the the straight and narrow
but actually where where sort of their
morals
got you know it's interesting i feel
like
um
i'm not even sure where i'm going with
that i know we were watching something
moral ambiguity okay okay moral
ambiguous that's the word okay
thank you and and and and
discovering that in a character because
you it's not always close
it's not always obvious to the the
audience and when we find that the one
that we suspected was the bad one
actually had more of
um a code of honor or ethics than one
that looked
squeaky clean and we thought we could
trust so um it's it's those gray areas
and yeah in the news and in life yeah
absolutely that's that's what i that's
what i enjoy um about that kind of work
um
i think that that
you know
i personally and i don't think everyone
feels the same way
but i
feel
that
work like that that enlightens you about
areas of the human condition
is edifying
because you have you you grow an insight
and then you have the potential
to take that insight
whether it is creatively or otherwise
you take it and you can
potentially evolve yourself
you know so that's